[Music]
pink and her nine-year-old daughter
willow
just dropped the video for their
heartwarming duet cover me in sunshine
and truly it's the heartwarming collab
our heart needs right now
thanks the grammy winner shared a clip
of the video on instagram friday
alongside the caption willow and i had
so much fun filming this one
in another post the proud mama wrote
quote cover me in sunshine with my baby
girl is out now
hope this one puts a smile on your face
even if it's far away
[Music]
yeah safe to say the sweet
mother-daughter video is guaranteed to
put a smile on your face
she's pitch perfect and she's loud which
is always good and in a statement
obtained by et on friday
pink shared the inspo behind the song
quote willow and i find
comfort in music so we're putting this
song out for no other reason than that
we hope it brings you sweetness
sunshine and comfort too just
imagine people
laughing
we will the 41 year old singer first
showed off her daughter's
impressive voice singing their collab on
monday
when she shared this video on tick tock
or i could just sing don't mean sunshine
yeah they're coming out
cover me in sunshine shower me in good
times
tell me that the world's been spinning
since the beginning
and everything will be alright just
cover me in sunshine
okay and get this willow's little
brother four-year-old jamison
tried his hand at the lyrics too cover
me in sunshine
all i need is sunshine
shower me with good times shower me with
good time we'll just call that
the family remix what version is that
low virginia
you